but it's impossible for a female to be
promiscuous on a long enough period of
time without devaluing herself because
she is [__] people she shouldn't be
there is no way she is sleeping with
endless men and all of them are either
high value men or treating her the way
she should be treated if you find a
woman who slept with 50 100 dudes she's
either [__] dudes which are at her
level or haven't worked hard enough to
try and get these shoes is too drunk to
realize he's a loser who plays video
games or she's [__] a top cheek who
barely texts her back so either way
she's dude she shouldn't be or a guy
who's at the level who doesn't give her
the right amount of attention for a
woman to find a guy who's truly on a
level who truly treats her the way she
should be treated that's once every
couple years if that you ain't just
gonna go out there a new dude every week
and say yeah he's worthy yeah he treats
me good enough to get my